The Internet and the World Wide Web and intimately tied to everyday lives. It
has put information that we seek at
our finger tips. Remedies for the common cold,
dinner recipes, sports updates, developments in the
Middle East, you name it. You will find
it on the internet. We know that the creation of such content happens from the
basement of individuals like you and me, as well as businesses such as CNN,
BBC, and NBC who's work it is to create such content. How is the content in
the internet stored and distributed? In the
first two lessons of this module, we looked
at the server end of the giant
scale services. How's a computational resources organized in
the data center? How is the data
organized internally in the computational. Nodes of
the cluster. And what is the programming
model for dealing with the big data associated
with giant scale services and for exploiting
all the computational resources that are available in
the server forms and data centers. In
this lesson, we'll look at content distribution networks.
That is How is information organized, located, and distributed
when we're looking for them? Once again, the issue is dealing with
the scale of the problem. The content is generated worldwide
and users are trying to access the content worldwide as well.